c'est un des plus importants chantiers
de toronto creuser un tronçon de rivière
d'un kilomètre de long près du centre
ville pour protéger une zone inondable
pour redonner son aspect d'antan à ce
qui a déjà été le plus important marais
du lac ontario
le quartier portuaire portland est un
secteur artificielle créée par des
décennies de remblayage à l'ère de
l'industrialisation l'embouchure naturel
de la rivière donne a été bouché puis
remplacé par un canal de dérivation
les torontois n'oublieront pas les
pluies diluviennes de 2013 phénomène
plus fréquents avec les changements
climatiques la zone portuaire ainsi que
les quartiers à l'est du centre-ville
sont exposés aux risques d'inondations
fréquentes puisque en cas de forte
tempête le débit de la rivière donne
peut être équivalent au trois quart de
celui des chutes du niagara
[Applaudissements]
pour prévenir les inondations extrêmes
dans le quartier portland comme celle
qui a causé des morts dans les années 50
le projet de protection du quartier est
devenu une priorité en 2001 pour la
ville la province et le fédéral plus
d'un milliard de dollars y est consacré
et les travaux seront complétés dans
cinq ans pour s'adapter et minimiser les
risques d'inondation il s'agit de
creuser un débouché naturel la rivière
le remblai produit une quantité
suffisante pour remplir le stade
olympique de montréal sera utilisé pour
eux aussi les berges
le projet de protection contre les
inondations s'inscrit dans la vision
plus large de la ville de redonner les
berges aux torontois
une fois le quartier portland protéger
contre les inondations la construction
résidentielle il sera enfin permise
vingt-cinq mille personnes pourront
vivre dans ce nouveau quartier
vingt pour cent des habitations seront
des logements abordables
axe toronto a fait le pari de poursuivre
sa croissance fulgurante en redonnant
plus de place à l'eau de la rivière
donne ici philippe leblanc radio canada
toronto